Leon - investigative reporter for The
Washington Post give it a book called
when children want children the urban
crisis of teenaged childbearing what's
it about it's about children wanting
children children a lot of children who
were becoming pregnant and mothers and
fathers in the urban slums urban slums
of America wanting children and
consciously actively engaging in sexual
activity to have children even at young
ages as young as junior high school
children we visited over a year ago
about the same subject after you wrote a
six-part series in The Washington Post
now the book what's different about this
book and the series that we talked about
before really the book talks about the
process of the process I went through to
get at the story the process of moving
into the slum district of Washington
Highlands here in Washington DC and
different aspects and different
confidences that are anonymous that were
given to me that I couldn't run in the
series okay and then after the series
ran I did additional research in North
Carolina in Granville County North
Carolina among elderly former tenant
farmers people who had sharecropped in
the heyday of sharecropping in the south
because I had found our shelter had
found in Washington Highlands patterns
that had grown out of economic necessity
at an early child bearing because
children were a very essential part of
sharecropping a landless black
sharecropper could not get a
sharecropping contract with a landowner
a farmer
unless he brought lots of children
childless couples were not accepted in
fact the childless couples in the south
there was a high rate of infertility
because they were they were very poor
medical services for black landless
sharecroppers a childless couple often
would adopt the adolescent children or
the children of an adolescent niece who
had not married and raised him as their
own
so they indeed could get a sharecropping
contract with a landowner children were
an explicit part of any tenant farming
agreement in the South particularly if
you were growing such cash crops as
cotton and tobacco which were profitable
but labor-intensive and children did
most of that labor
what's a sharecropper sharecropper is a
person who was agreed with the landowner
to grow a certain number of acres of a
major cash crop cotton or tobacco and in
exchange for their labor they're given
half of the crop at the at the harvest
to sell and ideally to receive a return
from their shares where sharecroppers
always black know there were other
tenant farmers but the majority of
sharecroppers in the south were black
particularly posts the civil war right
after the Civil War after emancipation
or after the Civil War really when the
south started going through the
Reconstruction period the freed slaves
were in mainly agricultural areas
because they had been an agricultural
labor force they had they had prom
skills and their labor and nothing
nothing much else and the South itself
was trying to recover from the ravages
of the Civil War so this tenant farming
system evolved really because the a lot
of these farmers and plantation owners
had lost their labor force and this
tenant farming system for the feed man
evolved shortly after that back to the
beginning of your series
when did you start investigating this
whole issue of children wanting children
I have been out of the country for about
five years as an African correspondent
for the post when I came back in January
of 84 a friend of mine told me that half
of the black children born in America in
1983 where the children of single
mothers and that 1/3 of those mothers
with poor adolescent girls well I
thought those figures were extraordinary
because I felt that children born of
adolescence in those
circumstances particularly in the
circumstances of poverty had no real
chance of climbing out of poverty
themselves the mothers didn't adolescent
mothers did not and the children would
not right so what we were talking about
or what I was seeing immediately I felt
were patterns and cycles over
generations of adolescent childbearing
where you had an expanding and almost
permanent underclass growing in many of
America's slum areas who's this on the
on the right as a adolescent mother
treated drea who had her first child and
only child so far
Marquis her son at age 15 out of wedlock
oh yeah always the case and these oh yes
in your situation all right right there
were some couples who she we des is now
married but she didn't marry the the
father of her child the father of her
child is in prison for armed robbery
that's where I interviewed him but there
was couple one couple who had two
children Jorge actions he had two
children by the age of 15 and she
subsequently married the father of her
two children who's this that's Tasha
Avon and her then boyfriend now husband
Reggie Wiley they had married but they
have never had children she was actively
trying to have a child because she was
afraid that she was infertile got a lot
of photographs here and it might help us
better understand some of the
personalities what's this photo this is
a family photo of a family council in
the home that she redid Dreier was
living in treated rare after she had
given birth to her son at age 15 had to
move 16 times in the first two years of
his life and she ended up in a homeless
shelter so here you see the home in that
photograph the home where she was taken
in after she left the shelter again that
Sherita dryer on the left with her son
Marquis and on the right the head of
household Lilian wheels with a note that
she writes to God asking for such basic
things
three boxes of chicken wings
a one-pound bag of flour six loaves of
bread one large bag of rice six cans of
sweet peas that's the Bible right there
in the rice it's very religious woman
let me read the cut line
on this one Lillian Williams with her
Bible and a note that she wrote in her
journal she wrote quote my Heavenly
Father you said you shall supply all my
needs and then cut mine says then listed
the items necessary to care for herself
and 16 others in her household how to
handle sixteen people on my house with a
lot of stress Lillian Williams herself
was the mother of eleven children and at
that time five of her grandchildren who
lived with her they were the children of
three of her oldest daughters and the
three daughters lived with her all borne
out all of the children born outside of
marriage this is Lillian Williams with
six of her seven sons she had seven sons
and four daughters and three of the
daughters when I met her were adolescent
mothers with five babies between them so
in that household you had seventeen
people who had Lillian Williams her 11
children and her five grandchildren one
of the things that I quickly discovered
particularly in a family like this one
of the things that had inspired me to do
the research is that people had used
adolescent Java and they said that the
girls were becoming pregnant to qualify
for welfare payments for welfare was
never enough to meet the family's needs
within any one month but at any rate
this is again Lily Williams and her
mother Lillian waters and a big hug at a
family picnic outside the public housing
dwelling that they live in all 17 people
were living in and you said that your
thesis is that the my friend here's
another photograph with you in it on
there on the Left who's right that's the
Lillian Williams mother's stepfather
down in the
sharecropping home that he still lived
in in Lenoir County North Carolina right
outside about nine miles north of the
town of Kinston North Carolina where I
had gone to interview him actually with
with his help the help of Lillian and
Lillian's mother in the top photo I went
back in the family in their family
history to the early 1900s and the
pattern there was very very clear
each woman going back to about 1909
first would let us hopper had two
children as an adolescent and then
married and she always married a young
man leaving his father's farm and
looking for a sharecropping arrangement
what would the men young man looking for
he was looking for a wife and a wife
with children had done what she had
produced two assets in the case of
lettuce hopper and she had proven her
fertility so she was very very
attractive so then he courted her then
she got into a serious courtship and the
two of them moved off of the woman's
father's farm Frank hopper and moved to
a share cropping arrangement with a
landowner but if the young man had
wanted to move on to that farm by
himself the landowner wouldn't have let
him wouldn't have enter this
sharecropping agreement with him and
that was the family's pattern right down
to when Lillian was growing up in her
grandmother's home again in the mill in
Lenoir County North Carolina until she
moved here in walked to Washington as an
adolescent yeah Leon - is gonna be with
us for 90 minutes we're gonna talk for
another 15 and open the phones for an
hour and we're talking about his book
new book women I'm sorry when children
want children and this is an outgrowth
of a series that was in The Washington
Post some six part series a couple of
years ago 86-90 January 1986 again let's
go back to the thesis you say that there
are a lot of people think that black
women have babies because they want more
welfare oh yeah yeah I mean one of the
first people who told me that when I was
again asking people informally why were
so many adolescent girls having children
one of my relatives was
first to say that the girls were having
babies to qualified to first get on the
welfare rows and then to qualify for
welfare payments but the girls knew that
even with one child the amount of money
that they get from an organization an
agency such as aid to families with
dependent children was never enough
money to meet the family's needs for one
month
here you see Lillian in the third week
of one of the months that I see in the
17 months that I spent with the family
in the third week of one of those months
writing a letter to God four basic food
items to feed 17 people she received in
welfare she received three hundred and
fifteen dollars three hundred and fifty
dollars a month out of that she paid a
hundred and seventeen dollars for rent
there was no phone in the house that
hadn't been for decades or years and
with the remaining approximately two
hundred dollars she was expected to feed
clothe and take care of seventeen people
it was impossible and there was never a
month at which at least by the third
week and always by the fourth week there
was absolutely no food in the house
nothing but running water in fact the
children in the house that were young
enough they were going to elementary
school or junior high school really
their motivation for getting up and
going to school was the food the free
food programs at the schools I remember
one morning when I first met the family
her fourth youngest daughter Jeanette
was late it was a very there was a
bitterly cold morning and her school bus
was late and I was really not aware of
this pattern and it was toward the end
of the month and I was sitting at the
kitchen table interviewing her mother
and Janet was standing by the door
waiting for the school bus and the bus
finally arrived and she turned to her
mother and this is when I really struck
me she had tears in her eyes because the
bus was so late and she said to her
mother now I won't have breakfast and
that's what she was looking forward to
that was how she started her day with
the free breakfast
school these are the closer I got to
these families the more I understood
about the circumstances the daily
circumstances circumstances under which
they live
we're a year from New York City
originally I grew up in Harlem right and
the Bronx what was the size of your
family ah ha ha I had two working
parents and we had two children that's
another point of this book that economic
mobility and a steady secure income
changes the behavior dramatically
Lillian's brother grew up in the same
situation that's regeneration household
on a sharecropping farm in the North
County North Carolina but he has
achieved a job they both have about the
same level of education they're both
junior high school dropouts but he got a
job as a clerk here in Washington City
Hall and it's a civil service position
his behavior has been dramatically
altered by that circumstances he lives
in Laurel Maryland in a suburban home
has a wife and one son and he's putting
all of his resources into that one son
in fact Lillian often has to call on him
for help because she can't make it alone
he understands it what did your parents
do for a living my father worked in the
post office and my mother was a New York
City registered nurse from New York City
home visiting visiting nurse program in
New York in Harlem right when did you
first leave Harlem Oh when I was 15 to
move to the Bronx and then one and then
after that at age 18 I went off to
college where Lincoln University and
then transferred here to Howard
University how did you get to go to
school my father worked two jobs to put
me through a private high school he not
only worked in the post office he took
on a second job I was a night security
guard to send me to private school from
the tenth grade on at Rhodes School in
New York City in Manhattan when did you
get interested in journalism yeah when I
really entered high school I became I
became active in a literary magazine
called opus high school magazine which
we thought contained
some of the greatest wisdom in the world
as just being at 16 I look back at some
of the things that we wrote you know but
15 16 and 17
that's a very exciting period in your
life and you the foundation for
journalism was there and they'll be high
school years did you get into journalism
because you like to write it because you
wanted to change the world thanks the
world I thought I could tell the world
how to change and therefore be an
effective agent of change and I really
believe that the pen is mightier than
the sword
that was my motivation essentially and
it's still is still that formation is
still with me I think I'm a lot more
cynical and I've been batted a lot as
life does to all of us as we grow up but
a basically underneath my motivation and
interests are really now and that's some
us to change the world
that changed early in my in my early 20s
and it became just to inform people let
people know what's really going on and
that is enough I think how did you get
your job at the Washington Post I
started working as a well when I
transferred to Howard it was in the fall
of 65 and Howard goes back now Howard's
right here in this city hi oh yeah yeah
how University in Washington and in
order to pay for my schooling I had to
do work steam cleaning buildings at
night on a scaffold and it started
getting cold you know with this big
steam gun blast sandblasting and steam
blasting windows I mean that windows
sandstone and so on in downtown
Washington and it was great pay for me
it was 350 an hour and I was still young
enough that I could work eight hours
from midnight to 8:00 in the morning and
then go to school for another full you
know I was carrying a full course load
and if you've got bitterly cold so I
started looking for an indoor job
because I could not go to school and not
work I had to pay my own way and I got a
job as a what it's called what was
called then this also dates me a copyboy
that term is no longer used I got a job
at the Washington Post that's a night
copyboard from 8:00 at night to 4:00 in
the morning which to me was just great I
think
was fantastic I was inside yeah I was no
longer swaying on a scaffold you know
several stories above the street and the
work wasn't that demanding it hadn't
been as demanding as working with that
hose it's the high pressure hose and I
got a head time to study at work was to
all of these things combined to they say
this is great you know but my plan then
really was to go to law school I wanted
to make I want to make a lot of money
but then that was in the fall of 65 and
then in June of 66 they asked me did I
wanted to take a shot at the reporters
intern program I did and I never left
I've been at the Washington coast ever
since except for two years in a piece
book well one of the things you talked
about in the beginning of your book here
is that you use the Bob Woodward style
of reporting to do this book what's that
that is you peel away the layers Bob the
leaves and I have come to accept and
understand that we all live with masks
in front of us and and these teenagers
were no different and that in order to
really get at the truth about their
genuine motivations for having children
I would have to spend a lot of time with
them and probably the first interview
would not be the truth and that was that
was true the first interview in each of
the first interviews with all the
principal persons and six families they
never told me initially that they had
intentionally become pregnant because
they wanted a child the range of
rationalizations or excuses were on what
I call adopted versions but untruthful
adopted versions where I got pregnant
because I didn't know anything about
birth control well the kids in this
community generally by ages of 11 and 12
were very very sophisticated about birth
control very sophisticated about their
reproductive capabilities much more than
I had been when I was 11 and 12 and they
were not ignorant about birth control
they had had extensive courses in sex
education in the sixth and seventh
grades in the DC school system something
that was not available to me in the New
York City school system when I was that
age
I had a lot of misinformation at 11 and
12 and my peers are telling me a lot of
lies at 11 and 12 but not something that
was formally done so I would really have
an understanding of human sexuality and
these kids were very sophisticated in
that area at the end in the epilogue you
write that not only the masks come off
of them but it came off of you after the
fact and you're now counseling or
involved they're talking with several of
the young ladies that you wrote about
tell us about they're still involved
with four of the six families all right
well what I did was after the surgery
and I dissolved a professional barrier
between myself and them really because
one of the most significant things that
I became aware of in this community was
the absence of information the parents
didn't have the information to pass to
their children in terms of the options
that were open to the children of
post-secondary education it's a big
example Sheila Matthews here is one of
the girls and I'm still actively
involved with that picture was taken
when she was 15 and six months pregnant
and she was talking at a the panel was
called the blue the blue ribbon panel
for teenage pregnancy prevention and she
was then in her junior year at Ballou
high school and she went back to school
finished high school she and Sherita
Kavita Draya reader has now married
that's again Sheila Matthews after her
son was born
Pee Dee and that's on the right that
Sheila and PD on the left and on the
right is Mario the father of the boy and
Petey and you're still in touch with
these folks oh yes what about your own
personal situation are you married to
get kids no I'm divorced I have two
children
my oldest daughter graduated from how
University in May got a job as a
physician's assistant August 1st and
moved out of her father's house August
2nd she said I love you dad but now it's
time for me to take off I said okay fly
and my youngest daughter lives with her
mother not too far from my house
together essentially because my youngest
daughter has cerebral palsy and I'm very
much active in her physical therapy and
so I keep a very close distance between
the two houses a mother and I agree on
one thing and that's we have to do
everything for her
so I'm actively involved in her daily
life speaking of [ __ ] children now
here's a picture you might want to
explain if someone oh yes Shawn main
Ford it's you at that time was in the
30s but her son that you see in the
foreground she's holding on her lap has
cerebral palsy and his name is tall's
Nelson she delivered him at the age of
16 and in the back are her twin boys on
the left is Lawrence and on the right is
Lionel but soon any fallout from your
original articles any government
official call up and say I now know
something I didn't know before I'm going
to change them yeah Otis Bowen the
former secretary of health under the
Reagan administration read the series
he's told me this isn't a face-to-face
meeting in his office dr. Otis Bowen
he's a most of his life a physician in
Indiana pediatrician I don't know if
he's a pediatrician I think a general
practitioner but I'm guessing I've
forgotten I knew at one point but at
anyway he and I sat down in his office
and we had a long talk after the series
ran he said that he was deeply affected
by the series and he had reorganized and
put several separate programs for
adolescent mothers into one body and was
really said we you know we really can't
get into the area of trying to prevent
the first pregnancy but I really want to
give these kids these support programs
that are necessary so they won't become
pregnant because 50 to 60 percent of
these girls have a second child within
two years of having it first and he said
when I learned that and he learned that
reading the series he said I said well
we really we're not doing enough and he
reorganized it brought in a associate of
his from Indiana guy named Wayne Stanton
to head this reorganized section of the
the federal Department of Health and
Human Service
well that was a great satisfaction to me
I mean was to see that kind of effort
just grow out of the series that's why
I'm in the business to inform people so
they can make choices and make decisions
and try to change bad situations and
that make you feel make me feel very
good to be honest maybe for very good
said that my my series had an impact not
gonna be able to find it when I want it
but i remember reading and i think in
your prologue where maybe it was your
acknowledgment where you were thinking
some people who took you through periods
out here it is you're thanking people
you say investigations desk editor David
Maraniss from Meredith Meredith marinus
kept me going at crucial junctures of
depression and anxiety and anxiety when
did you have depression and anxiety
often often particularly when I was not
I started the project in July of 1984
the Rita drea was the first of the girls
to tell me the truth in February 1985
well that's a long time eight months to
go without knowing whether you're going
to be successful or not and that and
then also that caused me a lot of
anxiety and then the circumstances these
kids faced the dire circumstances the
deep poverty I'm talking really about
the poorest of the poor I'm talking
about this term there's been come
popular while I was in Africa the
underclass so I'm really talking about
them and my depression was caused by
trying to work through my own mind
giving everything that I saw and
problems that I saw a family problem
school problems health problems
psychological problems all of these
factors together how do you begin to
turn the situation around and that had
caused me of
some some weeks of depression just
trying to work at solutions in my own
head knowing all the problems and trying
to say well where does the money come to
resolve all these problems where is the
political will today in the society
given all the problems that we're all
very
much aware of the huge national budget
deficit for example how do we begin to
go at turning the situation around I
didn't find in that process very complex
solutions to a very complicated
intricately interwoven problem Leon -
she's our special guest we have an hour
of calls to take and we're talking about
this book which is now in your book
stores when children want children and
it's not a long book how many words I
don't know it's about 270 pages and it's
published by William Morrow tomorrow and
you're gonna be on the circuit are you
where are you I just came back from the
circuit I'm still recovering from it
you've been out - how many sides did you
go to six cities Indianapolis go ahead
please and I just had two comments and
uh and a question and uh dr. Otis born
hearing in the neftis he's a medical
doctor so what I want to ask you about
you know only sharecroppers I heard you
I was born in Tennessee and we moved
from farm to farm and you was right
correct about 15 us enough family and so
we had first choice of going to a fall
sharecropping sure probably we didn't
get hair we only got a third now the
right your problem now they got hey but
the black sharecroppers in Tennessee I
cannot say for the way and my next
comment is on your subject about
children having a surgeon you know the
black line house but they don't have
nothing to look forward to Wendy when
you get out of school if they gather -
there's nothing there for me and that's
why they drop out early in eight and
then when you got an isle of mine it's
gonna reserve into something else like
my childbearing because this gonna
happen now but if you got a my question
the other me get through my question is
to you next time you write your book I
like
lucky give you a lot of good insight
though on what happened in the south
coast I was born and raised there you
know and I appreciate it for everybody
all right sir thank you
we're working somebody right if they
want they've got stories to tell you
right right what'd he mean he makes a
very good point I found that for these
kids having a child was a tangible
achievement many of them had lost their
economic foundations they had all
started school with a great deal of
enthusiasm but they had lost their
enthusiasm by the second and third
grades and stopped learning at that
point I didn't find a heavy commitment
on the part of the teachers in this
community to educate these kids they
were more actively engaged in
warehousing these kids they were
punitive measures taken if they didn't
get the subject matter but no remedial
steps making taken to help them get the
English Foundation and mathematics
foundation they needed to move from
grade to grade when I say punitive
measures they were left back until they
just got too old to be in the second
grade and then there was this push
forward to the third by the time they
got into the fifth and sixth grade sixth
and seventh grade where now you have a
daycare center out in the same community
when the DC school system opened a
daycare center for the first time last
fall at hot junior high school which is
in Washington Highlands I mean to me
that's an incredible admission as to how
much younger the girls are getting in
terms of Tao Barry before they would
just stay care centers in high schools
and that was a big traumatic event there
was no community reaction when they
opened the daycare center at a junior
high school it was like yes we
acknowledge that this is a growing
problem the girls are getting younger
they're having babies younger but at any
rate you had 15 and 16 year old kids in
the seventh grade with 11 and 12 year
olds what is what it what are they what
do they know by that time they know
implicitly or they've been told
explicitly that they're not going to
finish school what did they do they
moved to another arena of achievement
how do I become how do I move from
adolescence to womanhood how do I move
from adolescence to manhood produce the
Chow or have a child
it's another arena Kansas City Missouri
go ahead please
and I had to work hard and go to school
and I don't have any children I'm 32 and
I'd like to know when are we going to
have some program for black women and
minority women that don't go out and get
pregnant and have children what do you
mean television programs are yeah when
are we going to give some
acknowledgement to the achievement of
people that do don't go out and have
unwanted children and they're taxpaying
citizens and I feel real sympathetic but
every time I turn around is the program
talking about how these poor women with
five or six unwanted children by five or
six unwanted men are and I just think
this is really terrible motivate let me
ask you you are you suggesting to what
we ought to do is invite somebody like
yourself on here to talk about how you
are successful in your life okay thanks
does she have a point I'm interested in
the crisis I think these kids are
producing the the fact that these
children are producing such large
numbers of children to me is a crisis
and I think we should give more and more
attention to it so I'm really not in
their corner and that respect Manteca
California go ahead please I am I find
this very interesting then especially
for making from since I'm a basically a
white conservative Reaganite I've been
far I had four kids of my own and it's
very interesting to see this problem but
solution seems to be very difficult to
grasp wondering if your guess would have
any ideas there's there's a sawa
the black economist has some interesting
theories about the problems of the black
but teenage pregnancy crosses all lines
where I live in the San Joaquin Valley
it seems to be
the same problem exists in all races
here too and as a father who luckily
escaped this hopefully they're all gone
into college and getting through it
seems to be a high dropout rate even out
here among all classes in and I agree
something has to be done but what is the
solution
Thanks so the black kids that I spent a
lot of time with I think the significant
solution is that they need a lot of work
at elementary school levels if they get
into junior high school and having
gotten the elementary school from
foundation they're not going to be able
to do junior high school work and their
attitudes toward having a child become a
positive attitude that they want to talk
that's a tangible achievement in a world
that they see when they look at it these
are not dumb kids are undereducated kids
and they look at their future they
understand that they don't have much of
a future and that their opportunities in
the job market a ver very limited they
realize that having a child then becomes
something that worthwhile becomes a
rational choice for them north desert
massachusetts go ahead please my brother
is also a graduate of Rhode school so I
was happy to hear about that and my
parents also sacrificed a great deal to
send him there and the other children in
our family I went to a parochial school
but my question is and in our experience
at any rate my parents were never
attached to the government and they work
real real hard and all kids in our
family work real hard to to make it on
our own and my parents always showed us
the possibilities and and I really feel
real sorry for those things that there
is no no reason to go to school and no
reason to work hard and we always had
those possibilities but the other thing
was that we did not have that umbilical
cord to the government we didn't go to
government schools and we didn't live on
the government Dole and yeah my parents
everyone who I would would here and
there and they used some food stamps
because perhaps it was a layoff involved
but they got out of that as soon as they
couldn't and I think they only
that we're gonna actually get out ever
change anything is to make it on our own
that's the way it's always been I think
your life who's that and the government
just makes us so dependent we're all
like a bunch of children all right thank
you ma'am - I understand what she's
saying I found that a lot of the parents
in this in this particular community
suffer from very long periods years long
periods of unemployment underemployment
very marginal employment or seasonal
employment employment that involves a
lot of labor and when the labor is not
needed particularly at construction
sites could be young adult males they're
laid off for very very long periods they
laid off when the weather is inclement a
lot of difficulties with the adults
raising children in this community to
find full-time that was my point that I
made earlier and the children see the
same pattern okay well you know I did
find this there's another thing that I
didn't realize is that a lot of the
families in this community dead set
against any form of abortion a child was
a child from the stem from the moment of
conception and there wasn't a lot it
wasn't any great area and there was a
black and white issue for most family
and the number of the girls before they
became pregnant knew the family attitude
about abortion and knew that once the
pregnancy became known what she told her
mother or waited until she began to show
and her mother discovered the pregnancy
that there would be no question of
abortion
because she already knew that her mother
was against the portly and that was
something I hadn't realized also I don't
think it's possible to show this well we
can try it this is a table that says
adolescent birth rates from 1940 to 1984
and James see if you can get down here
on this thing and I don't I don't know
whether it makes any sense at all yeah
maybe you can help us with this well
what is happening and one of the other
one of the I think the Kansas City call
a alluded to that over here you have a
column of blocks and you can see from
beginning about ninth in the early 1970s
while the adolescent childbearing rate
here down is higher it begins to go down
until it's declined in 1984 to about 95
children
let's stop and explain each rope very
quickly there okay here you have all
races here you have White's aged under
the age of 15 and this row you have
White's 15 to 19 yeah up until 1969
blacks were included in a entire
arrangement of minorities but after 1969
they were counted that's why you have
the asterisk after 1969 they were
counted by themselves but still the
category was 95 percent black with
others others being Native Americans and
aging that finger goes up there right
then the early 70s that right don't
figure right over here and then it
starts to go down right and on the next
page goes right it goes down there the
more what does that mean for for black
girls under the age of 15 for babies
born to every 1,000 mothers for black
girls 15 to 19 100 babies born to every
1,000 adolescent mothers that adolescent
girls web and that's figures really gone
there right and oh I don't know why but
it's declining all over the country very
very slowly what has gone up as the
number of white adolescent girls both
the living in poor rural areas like the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan and
Appalachia the adolescent childbearing
rate has
up and among white adolescence is going
up middle-class adolescents in urban
areas whereas among black middle class
urban dwellers it's going down
significantly and it's not really a
significant educate that they are
violating and that if you mess with the
bull you get the horn thank you well I
attended three the spend six families
that I really concentrated on attended
three community churches and I attended
two churches talked to the ministers
about this problem essentially
particularly in the family of lily and
Williams premarital sex she went to a
very fundamentalist church the Church of
the Living God premarital sex and sex
with somebody who was not saved outside
of the institution of marriage was
forbidden but at the same time in
interviewing her children they didn't
see at that point in their lives that
the church had any right to say what
they did and what they did not do in
their sex lives they made a shop
demarcation
differentiation between what they were
willing to live with under church law
and what they were not willing to live
with and the church's admonitions and
teachings against premarital sex or sex
outside the institution of marriage
bearing children outside the institution
of marriage for something that they all
rejected me on this picture that we were
on right there it shows two people just
got married but these are their kids
these are worth of children this is um
joy Jackson in the wedding gown and she
had two girls by Tony Smith her husband
that you see in the same picture their
two daughters were born to joy by the
time she was fifteen years old and in
the lower picture you see them after
they've been married for in thanks for
your call
now that's what the president called the
man it is called the things that he said
was generally the first
defense in this project in terms of the
people that I was interviewing that's
why it took repeated interviews over the
17 months to peel away the layers of
what I call a defensive adopted version
for the outside outside consumption it
took months and months to get to know
the person and begin to peel away the
layers with repeated interviews I was
surprised that so they agreed to sit
through the interview so I think at the
bottom there was a willingness to have
the truth come out and it just took a
long time for them to verbalize it
generally even with the rationales and
the reasons that the last caller just
gave generally there was under all the
layers of obfuscation a general
motivation to produce at all up to have
a job San Diego California you're next
well you're on the air yes I'd like to
uh somewhat disagree and agree with your
gift and I as a black male 37 years old
with no kids I disagree with black
intellectuals who spend more time giving
statistics or analyze logistics about
the black community and next point being
that most of the welfare programs are
designed for they call it women infants
and children and if you if you look at
them closely they think that's a
financial incentive for it any female to
become pregnant after the age of 15 and
for any male to be the unofficial father
if you want to call it that because for
just the financial gain and on top of
that the black female being more
successful in the community without a
black male around so I lack - a gift to
sort of give it his opinions on that
corner let me ask you do you think Leon
- is a black intellectual just talking
about statistics I think so I've heard
too many of these peers now that the
blacks that you see in the media or art
giving a account of what's going on
black neighborhood are so far removed
for
the real black experience that they can
they have no connection other than just
a statistical connection that the black
neighborhood let me ask you though did
you listen to the beginning of this
where mr. dash talked about spending 17
months in right inside the homes of some
six different families is that does that
help a daughter you still think that
that's that's not not worth the
experience I don't I think it's diable
for him but when he talks give write the
book then and reference that being
there's a real black community you have
a what's going on black me in the black
leadership and black intellectuals being
so far removed from the real black
experience that they would be or
classified as a dark-skinned white
evaluating the black community okay
thank you well you know that first oh I
disagree with him entirely I think I got
very close to these families and I ended
up debunking a lot of myths one of the
myths one of the very powerful mists
that he himself gave is that these kids
see a motivation or one of the
underlying motivation for having
children is to qualify for welfare
payments I found that in every case not
to be true in fact there was a lot of
resistance and embarrassment and shame
of going through the certification
process and recertification process that
you have to go through every six months
in one case one of the daughters of
Lillian Williams became so traumatized
by that experience that she put off
going for fifteen months and so the
mother said I cannot support you and
your child and if you're going to eat in
this household you will have to certify
yourself for welfare payments and they
literally had to coerce Poochie into
going now and going through the process
and one of the older girls as soon as
she got a job as a stapling sales tax on
clothes for a local department store she
went down to the welfare board and had
herself taken off and and in no case
where her family was on welfare or an
adolescent mother was on welfare was the
money that she was receiving enough to
feed and clothe that child for a month
and that to me is not a high incentive
to have children to get a
they are they were really having
children to be personal human needs not
for welfare income New Brunswick New
Jersey you're next go ahead please good
morning morning I just like the first of
all pay a tribute to c-span you really
turned my life around in terms of how
you report and what you do I think
you're doing a magnificent job thank you
sir
secondly the woman who called vero you
spoke about having something done for
the people who managed not to have
children out of wedlock
I think that there's some more looking
into because this is the role model that
I don't think we get enough of thirdly
mr. Dash's book which I haven't read yet
obviously brings home to us another
problem that we've heard about what not
but like so many things in America we
don't really appreciate until somebody
hits us over the head with a 2x4 but
what I'd like to ask him and wish him
well I'd like to ask you what do you see
as needing to be done by the state
government by the churches by the
federal government or whoever assent
action I sent I I mentioned earlier that
essentially these kids really lose it in
elementary school in America where
whatever political spectrum you come
from or out of a few people quibble
quibble with the success of the
headstart program one of the one of the
most successful of the Johnson
administration anti-poverty programs did
that Boeing agree with that too
I didn't we didn't talk about Head Start
we were talking about very very late in
the game and that's adolescence so this
is my own conclusion that if we can get
these kids or give these kids let me
give you an example Ayatollah I
mentioned earlier that I interviewed the
father of sherita's child in prison he
was 19 years old in what is called a law
News Center when I interviewed with
February of 1985 name is Wayne Willa and
interviewed him over several days about
how he had become a father at the
age of 17 or 16 at that time he was 19
when I interviewed on earth he when I
looked at the paperwork on him after you
Sena he was 19 years old was reading at
a third-grade level and had been in
school up to the age of 16 had had gone
as far as the ninth grade in school that
he was reading at a third grade level
told me everything that he really is
dysfunctional in the job market and
that's what most of these kids they
don't see a future how can you get to
the ninth grade in any school system
that really cares about educating you
how can you get to the ninth grade
reading at a third grade level to me
that's incredible next call Waterbury
Connecticut for Leon - I like to mention
mr. - incan in connection with a woman
previously called being a black woman
mention about to him that what he needed
to is bring on more positive things in
connection with all in the black
community my personal experience I feel
that the whites of America realized that
facts are making a lot of great strive
so these are not faces the problems and
problems what he's writing about is
about young children having babies
because that was one of those to myself
and I find that most of the time the boy
and the girl be one the babies and using
a conversation during the time of
courting uses the girl bringing up when
we get married that's going to happen
and that don't happen when the baby
whenever you do get a baby your girl
gets pregnant both of you all have this
maternal feeling toward that favor but
at the same time you become afraid
fortunate with me I'm an aggressive type
person and the hard stuff going in
schools is in the 10th grade and this
was done through adult school but what
wasn't open to blacks as a whole is that
where a white person could do it if they
didn't have
high school education that were trade
that they can get into whereas with the
pledge the trees wasn't open more or
less forced my way into the trade and at
the time when my former girlfriend
conceived I made 160 dollars a month and
I'd live Goodall for that cuz I was
hauling my mother and I found that that
wouldn't do for a family we got married
everything I found that when do for
family and being the type of person I am
you know if one who always will push
ahead which is not just like fair
everybody's not made to be a leader okay
thank you how about his point in there
that a black male has less opportunity
than a white male in the trades
oh yeah the trades will the trades have
been a major point of particularly trade
unions have been a major point of
contention in terms of integrating the
unions because the work in the trades
have really come through the unions
craft unions and craft union employment
or joining a craft union and going
through the stages become across skilled
tradesmen has generally been along
family lines where a father passed it to
his sons and uncle passed it to his
nephews or you passed it to younger
cousins really on family lines well the
trade union foundation is generally
white male so the white males are
generally gonna pass it on to other
family members Daniel L David Ellwood
who has done studies of this at the
Kennedy Center at Harvard he did these
studies in Chicago he and I had a long
talk about it and he found that within
Chicago even in area even in black
communities where they were where there
was employment generally young white
males got that those jobs even in black
communities in Chicago because of
informal networks with the owners of
these operations through their families
so to him it was it was a very clear
pattern about 30 minutes to go with our
special guest this morning Leon - who is
an investigative reporter with the
Washington Post and has this book on the
in the bookstores right now when
children want children los angeles
california go ahead please
morning Highness - gasps I see by your
face that dis really hit you and it
matters to you a lot I am NOT gonna say
I'm a black woman because I'm not I'm a
white woman I was raised in a middle
class family I didn't have a child when
I was a teenager I had a child I was 21
and then I was divorced when she was a
year old I raised it by myself and
worked in a doctor's office didn't make
much at 31 I became ill with systemic
lupus I'll never be able to work again I
am calling phone calls three phone calls
about a girl about how you make so much
money on welfare this makes me angry I
had to be on it
the welfare system perhaps you does not
help you
what I see when I go down to those
welfare places is mostly women with
children they degrade you they give you
food stamps so that when you go into a
grocery store the people behind you talk
and snicker
Connor what is in your opinion would be
a change that you would bring about in
the welfare system or the food stamp
system that would either lend more
dignity to the situation or gets you off
of the off of the welfare system well in
my situation I write for Social Security
twice now and because of my age and work
experience um they said so tickets at a
movie theater but for someone maybe
that's healthy a good job training
program
train these people training with
computers beat them how to read if they
can't read
alright let's leave it at that and see
if mr. Nash agrees I do I don't think
the programs now really having a
significant impact job corps included
three of their children in Lillian
Williams family went through job
training job training in Job Corps after
they dropped out of school and they were
not able to get in any employment in the
areas where they had been trained oh and
I wasn't sure about the level of
training it was very unclear about just
how skilled they were they thought they
was killed but obviously the people that
were looking at them as possible
employees didn't think too highly of the
skills that they had picked up in the
Job Corps I do feel however that one of
the second things that I talk about a
little bit in the book is besides
education an emphasis on education more
resources at the elementary school level
is a program a full employment the thing
that struck me in all six families after
I had grown close to them was that I
could tell by just walking into
someone's house who had recently been
laid off who had been out looking for a
job all day who was experiencing great
difficulty in getting employment and all
of it was tied to the inability to get a
steady secure job and I think that a lot
of the negative behavior that I saw was
the result of the inability to affirm
yourself through work really so I would
agree with you in some respects yes
Cleveland Ohio go ahead please good
morning I'd like to support mr. - and
his wonderful work I believe woman to
get welfare and the read
for bearing children it reminds me of
having gone to Mexico City and being
almost shocked getting out of the zona
rosa and into the population where
culturally it was very very desirable to
have children it gave them a sense of
community in it would be anathema to
them to have abortion or to not to have
this sense of community and I think I
came home a bit depressed because the
population of course caused many
economic problems and it posed the
conundrum that mr. - is posing would he
have any ideas how you would keep that
sense of community find alternative to
bearing children it's a very real I
think thank you I don't know really how
to answer your question because you're
talking about a structure in Mexico and
how do you formulate a structure like
that in in the in America I really don't
have a good answer for you I think that
people obviously people who are in the
same levels of income or exist at the
same level of poverty grouped together
in particularly geographic locations
because of the economic circumstances
you probably if you are earning a decent
income probably have a better sense of
community in the United States than you
would if you're surviving just day by
day and struggling in a very poor
community its wracked by drug traffic
and crime like like this this area this
area where I lived for a year and a half
in Washington Highlands is now an area
that is experiencing a very high
homicide rate actually since I moved out
because of the way the crack trade has
moved in there and a lot of the young
men that I'm talking about who are very
badly educated see the crack trade as a
ready source of income deeply involved
in it and a lot of them these young men
of shooting each other and dying each
day line of Georgia go ahead please
mother because I started having kids in
the early fifties in my teen years I had
two daughters and the welfare system in
fact helped me because it helped me to
realize that I did not want to be in
that situation I was in a housing
project for shortly at a time and I
appreciated the help that they gave me
to me it depends on what you want out of
life
how you look at I have two daughters
what is married when it's in college now
I'm a nurse I relocated to Atlanta
Georgia and they have no kids because I
said an example of how life really was I
told them that I had a dream and I
wanted them to have a dream my dream was
to be somebody the Beast don't want so
now I'm great and they're great thank
you
I glad to she raised that but
unfortunately her case is a rare case
and studies done by the National
Institutes of Health the best predictor
for an adolescent girls age at first
birth is her mother's age at first birth
a lot of repeated path patterns her case
I think is one of the good and
successful instances that are all too
rare that the pattern is broken because
of the determination of the mother I
found a lot of the adolescent adult
women who had been adolescent mothers
are really caught in deep cycles of
despair and just in depression because
of their circumstances and a lot of them
like Lillian Williams turned to church
and I think that keeps them saying
because they're dealing with an
incredible level of depression and an
incredible level of stress just in
feeding your children if you run out of
food but fourth week of a month and it's
a it's a good week before the check is
coming and you've got toddlers five
toddlers running around your house and
no milk in the house nothing but running
water and that that that's real stress
that's real stress and you turn to the
church for salvation and also the
churches do play a role in this respect
because they are very much aware people
in churches are very much aware of what
happens at the end of the month and
that's when the church giveaway food
giveaway programs are most active this
program is seen around the world on us
is world net our next call goes to unter
Boyan Jen West Germany go ahead please
yes I would like to comment on the fact
of welfare and where people think how
much money you get and everything else I
had my daughter two weeks before I was
20 years old I was not stupid I could
get a job but you can't go out and get a
job with a brand-new baby on your hands
so this wipes out the woman's theory
from before number one number two you
are definitely right AFDC might cover
you for two weeks what are you gonna do
for the third and fourth week how do you
tell a child who's hungry I'm sorry I
got nothing to give you
and I'm a white woman I'm a white woman
who is brought up in Detroit Michigan in
a middle-class section what are you
doing nothing to do with where you come
from or what you know or how good your
education is what are you doing what are
you doing or when the man takes off this
is a hard thing to deal with and where
are these people come in and say okay I
can come in and show you well I did it
all on my own with but I don't have no
kids mister - well I agree with the
caller Apache Junction Arizona go ahead
please yes good morning
it doesn't make any difference what
color you are whether you're black or
Asian or white
or any other thing it's a matter of fact
is that the women who have the children
have to have the love that helps rear
these children and the proper
environment I mean you can be very poor
hybrid for children by myself from the
ages of one two three and four through
college
and I am I had my family was this think
horrendous thing what'd he call it they
were deceased in that other words but I
managed because I love my children and
to this day my children still trust me
and believe in me because I gave them
that
but I also had good friends wonderful
black friends wonderful Spanish American
friends and but it's not the fact that
you're poor it's the fact what your
attitude is and how much love you give
your children you grew that land that in
many respects the one of the things that
again startled me is the in the case of
Lillian Williams to use as an example
Lillian Williams said that early in
childhood she equated early in
adolescent childhood she equated sex
with love because in her family love was
not an emotion that was expressed and
she said that she had never had anyone
tell her as she loved her so she always
felt emotionally deprived emotionally
needy so she saw the attention she
received from males as an expression of
that love
and it kept her and I'm quoting from her
running from man to man and she didn't
realize until well into her adult years
and particularly after she had turned to
the church that what she was really
doing
was equating companionship and sexual
activity with love and it wasn't and
left it very dissatisfied what's the
reaction if any from six young women in
here and your book and a lot of the
others when they know that there's a
book out there with their pictures in it
and they're being quoted uh-huh any well
they're very reactions among the four
that I'm still very close to that's
they're happy to see it in book form
they're happy they think and they feel
they caught a lot of criticism from
their families after the series appeared
in 86 not as much today because things
people have absorbed the material but
they're happy in terms of from their
standpoint seeing or trying to have the
incidents of adolescent childbearing
stopped halted or turned around by
sharing their stories sharing the the
dilemmas that they went through the
difficulties they've been through and
hard times that they went through for
the family of Lillian Williams Williams
she is a very brave woman but she's been
under a considerable amount of stress
and pain because or was in the past
because of the reaction of some aunts
and uncles in terms of the abuse that
her stepmother received that I talked
about from sexual abuse from the
stepfather and then the fact that
Lillian herself wasn't molested by the
same man a decade or so later that
created some turmoil in the family but
Lillian felt the truth of that situation
should come out so people would have a
clearer understanding of how that abuse
led to the pattern of adolescent Auburn
on the part of her mother and also on
her part Earl Arkansas for Leon - go
ahead please yes I was I'm a teacher of
white middle class woman who teaches in
a small town who had taught Laster in a
small town mostly black and in the
school that I thought I taught remedial
reading
on computers through a jtpa program most
of my the school was comprised of 90%
black children and most of the children
that I got what they weren't sure in
their high school age but needed to be
remediated in reading most of them read
on 3rd and 4th grade levels which you
know shocked me as it did you but this
is more this was not this is more the
rule than the exception what I found was
that these kids like you said are not
ignorant children these children are
smart children that just needed to be
remediated more than anything and
through determination they were highly
motivated and their grade level of
reading improved over the course the
year as far as like pregnancies which I
had of a lot of girls who were pregnant
I too made an observation that between
my between the two of us even though she
was a lower class black a poor black
girl they may have been poor black and I
was middle-class with children our needs
were the same for these children
we still loved our children in the same
way and so I agree with you and that
this having these babies even though it
keeps them out on a poverty level it
does fulfill a need within these
children and one more observation
the thing that I've the thing that I
noticed most of all is what we need to
do in these poor communities is to pour
money pour tons of money into
remediating the children I agree with
you a hundred percent about teaching the
children early on because once they get
past third grade they've lost it and if
we don't pour money into remediating
these young adults they're lost okay
thank you again that's my point and if
you don't put the money in it and the
effort in at elementary school by the
second and third grade these kids are
lost
Stuttgart West Germany go ahead please
yes I'm calling this to raise an issue
that I'm been listening here and I'm I'm
I live in West Germany here I'm a
contractor I have a family I worked for
this position I came from a middle-class
family but I'm also one who has
relatives close family relatives who are
raising our own welfare raising four
children
and what I see she's married I don't
understand her husband doesn't work
is this an abuse of the system in your
own opinion well I don't know I don't
know why our husband doesn't work
why doesn't work this you have a medical
disability or is it sound of the problem
no why can't I don't have an answer for
you unless you can give me what is
rationale is for not working does he
have a drinking problem or or some other
problem that keeps him incapacitated
from unable to work none none I don't
know I will have an answer for you
caller where were you from in the United
States taken where did you come from in
the United States originally yeah and
why are you in West Germany are you
there are you living here permanently
no I'm here as I'm here the government
contractor you see any difference in the
society and Stuttgart than you did when
you were here in the United States about
the problems we're talking about
definitely can you give us an example
Havel why not the the Germans use a
socialized system which it's education
and everything comes through the
government yes they do get taxed more
and the taxes paid into the social event
for education and things where you just
don't have the problems that we have
with the world fair system in the United
States all right thank you
is he putting his finger on the opposite
end of the way we do things in this
country and do you think that if more
money was put in the system more
government involvement that it would
solve the problem no I'm not too certain
about that I've seen a lot of government
programs that I think service or serve
the people who operate those programs
more than they service the people that
they're aimed at and I genuinely believe
that I think the best return on your
dollar is to educate these kids give
them a solid educational foundation
reduce if you've least kids I'm not
saying that these kids come to school as
genteel angels these are rough
kids I know I've taken a silver some of
them to school and I was drawn into the
family emergency network at different
times and what do you mean by rough
aggressive assaults have been profane
they grow up in those circumstances and
the boys and girls are a lot rougher lot
tougher genuinely tough ready to fight
and fight each other and fight an adult
we are now the leading country
supposedly in the United States was in
DC and homicides per capita where Isis
happened in the last couple of years why
I think a lot of these kids are involved
in it a lot of the kids that I'm talking
about particularly the male's I'm
working on a project now and I have been
to the last 18 months dealing with the
children of criminal recidivists and
criminal families involved in crime
generations of crime oran I've been
spending I've been spending 18 months
going in and out of the cell blocks the
18 cell blocks of the DC jail and I've
learned quite a bit when am I gonna see
that work you're gonna see the first
series in watts in the second series on
families in late spring or summer but
did you see this coming you started this
whole process a couple years ago and
it's one of the eye-openers one of the
eye-openers what are the eye-openers for
me is that not only is producing a child
an area very arena of achievement for
the young men like William wheeler 19
years old and unable to read but also
this parallel value system that they
shift into away from mainstream values
into a parallel value system says as
okay to get money from dealing crack
well if you're going to deal crack then
the street term is shaky you shake crack
on the corner I don't know where the
term comes from there is a lot of the
incredible terminology but if you're
gonna deal crack it's a very dangerous
profession it's very lucrative but very
dangerous and when you're in the
situation where someone's approaching
you they're threatening you or someone
owes you money you're going to shoot
first and ask questions later
it's like Dodge City so our idea of what
the West was like a lot like in this
parallel value system besides dealing
crack and carrying guns it's okay to
commit armed robbery it's okay to
burglarized houses it's okay to steal
cause the expression among the kids I'm
talking about kids we lose sight of that
these are kids they haven't even entered
the age range where they begin a
concrete adult thinking they still think
as children love you missed that they
don't think that if I do this then that
is the consequence that's adult thinking
that's not adolescent thinking I add a
lessons think of themselves and I think
this contributes to the homicide wait
we're now experiencing adolescence think
of themselves as invulnerable and
immortal once you understand that you
begin to understand a lot of adolescent
behavior Fremont California for Leon -
go ahead please
bird calling
I've enjoyed you uh so far and speaking
on children having children I work with
youth before and what I think is the
raising of children is so much different
now than when you and I and some others
was raised it's not don't get pregnant
or you'll end up on welfare you go to
school and get an education that's not
being said in a lot of homes because
some of the mothers were young and these
young mothers are producing their girls
are much younger than they are are
producing and this is okay and a lot of
families even though they're living very
poor and having a very hard time the
same thing with a lot of your crime in
your a lot of your crack dealers they're
coming from families that believe in cry
I mean they are quoting the President
Nixon I've talked to a lot of youth and
they think well you big people the big
white people steal so why not I okay
thanks well you that well I will agree
with her that a lot of these kids are
I'm talking about the poorest of the
poor and particularly on this project
I'm working on now a lot of these kids
get into crime their parents are
involved in crime in the in these
communities they're one phenomenon that
I'll share with you that I really was
totally unaware
until I started working on the
adolescent pregnancy project and that is
the pressure put on the adolescent boy
the oldest boy and a large family a
large welfare family to bring income
into the house and there are a lot of
questions asked I began to discover
about where the money's coming from now
the mother knows that he doesn't not
working at Roy Rogers flipping
hamburgers she just knows that from his
own activity it's not scheduled activity
but there aren't a lot of questions
asked and there's a lot of kids like
this that deal on it but don't use it
they think that this is the business
about being immortal and invulnerable
it's very strong adolescent thinking
they think that they're not going to use
it eventually they begin using their own
product and eventually things fall apart
but at the outset particularly if I can
go to hawk junior high school and I've
interviewed adolescents about this if I
can show up at Hart junior high school
doesn't matter that I read it a third
grade level and I'm in the seventh grade
or the eighth grade if I can flash a
fact rolled dollar bills then there's no
sense in having that role the dollar
bills unless I'm going to flash it
because I want people to know that I
have it what does that do for me it
gives me incredible amount of prestige
among the boys and the girls who I want
to have that prestige among there's an
instance of great motivator Milwaukee
Wisconsin for Leon - go ahead please
situation bad conditions which lead
people to want to escape but to the
point that was going to make Joyce
Ladner wrote a book about 20 25 years
ago maybe I'm dating
Mauro's tomorrow
and in its he class the individual the
young women in the in it in two
categories what she called mature and a
sexual has been sexually mature and
sexually mature and she drew the idea is
essentially long lines that to the
extent that you became sexually mature
to escape the circumstances and
surroundings to that degree and extent
she ended up having babies out of
wedlock or in the early age and to the
degree in extent that you put off this
sexual maturation to that degree extent
you escaped on an educational career and
cultural level career ladder out to the
the other way out and I was basically
wondering whether now after well the
period of time twenty twenty-five years
if this particular item that she had
developed there had essentially expanded
out into the rest of the community
thank you I don't know that it exists
painted out into the rest of the
community the thing that I found is that
among these poor black kids there were
the same patterns of existence the same
of patterns of the life you if you began
using birth control pills
among these girls you wanted your
girlfriend's to know know that you told
your girlfriend because it move you from
the status of child to that if a
question if you became sexually active
you wanted people to know that because
again it moved just status from that a
child to adolescent these were specific
rites of passage again if you wanted to
move from the status of adolescent to
the status of woman you became pregnant
and you had a child you go you went full
term it was not considered a full
passage if you became pregnant and had
an abortion there were a lot of kids in
this community who had abortions also
but I really focused on the issue of
those girls and boys who actually wanted
children next call bond West Germany go
ahead please thank you
hi this is Rafael receiver and I'm
calling from bond in West Germany
and I just returned here at Sivan after
about being back in New York for about a
year and I'd like to bring the attention
to the poor class in New York State that
I have came in contact with and because
I was only back for about a year I got
back into security and insecurity as
many people know the majority of the
people are in minimum wage now the fact
that surprised me is that they're all 99
percent of these people come from broken
homes and upset families and they also
collect Social Security and Welfare and
all that kind of thing and I was an
extent because I was living at my
mother's house I was back at my mother's
so I didn't have to worry about paying
rent and things like that but right now
I'm 24 and supporting my family I have a
wife and a daughter
and if I was back in New York during the
same amount of money I just couldn't
afford it myself and I think I would be
forced eventually to turn into wealth it
turned to Welfare myself no what I'm
saying is that until there is a great
amount of people willing to work for
average minimum wage we're always gonna
have the same problem all right - Thank
You Leon - I don't know what to say I
agree with you I don't know that I do or
I don't and that's the that's as far as
I go on it last call for Leon Dyson Los
Angeles your next morning like the
comments in the sir - that I too was a
childhood pregnancy case at the age of
16 I agree totally that the problem is
not out of poverty so much it's more out
of an emotional and mental
state of mine as a child at the time and
most times it is out at out of not
having love as he stated and as he
stated William said in in her case it's
a lack of something in most cases it is
a like of love and we did an idea turn
to sex as a means of satisfying that
love
however poverty just asked to it because
if it wasn't on for abortions the middle
class if you started taking running
surveys you would find it in the middle
class there are just as many pregnancies
but because their parents can afford to
let them have abortions or give them
birth control pills you do not hear of
that part of the society
all right Los Angeles we're out of time
thank you your reaction I agree with her
that there are more abortions among
middle class adolescents considerably
more black or white then there are among
poor poor girls and there are I would
just want to add that there are about a
million pregnancies in America each year
adolescent pregnancies and about half of
those end up in abortion and they're
about at half end up with the birth of a
chop Leon - our guest for the last 90
minutes he's a native of New York City a
graduate of Howard University here in
Washington DC an investigative reporter
with the Washington Post and he is the
author of this book when children want
children
published by William Morrow in your
bookstores thank you thank you thank you
Brian thanks to our audience for your
observations and your questions